So, I saw more people fights
with their co-founders and
breaking up with their co-founders.
Then I saw people were sticking
with their co-founders for years.
I think that one of the most popular
reason, one of the most common reasons,
that the companies fail is because
the co-founders fights and
they can't work together for
a long time.
It happens mainly because I
think there's two main reasons.
The first reason is
the definition of working hard.
Sometime the values of
one co-founder is very different
than the values of the other one.
If I believe that working hard
is working 18 hours a day, and
not taking vacation, and not taking
salaries, but my co-founder's values say
that it's working 9 to 5 but working
really hard, that sometimes collide.
You follow values that our
employees should be doing
120% and they need to stick to doing all
nighters and we need to ship of the day,
and the other one thinks that
it should be more mellow.
It's probably going to break some time.
Another reason is not being
sure what everybody's role is.
So we decided that you're the CEO but
I'm going to be involved in everything
that you're going to decide even
though that my definition is the CMO.
This is also not going to work.
And if the CEO decides to micromanage
his cofounder This is also going to
break, and those reasons are, I think,
the main reasons that the companies
fail because of founders.